[Music]
this morning in our emmy-nominated
series note to self we hear from rock
climber Alex Honnold the 33 year old is
one of the biggest names in the
adventure sport last summer he became
the first and only person so far to
climb Yosemite zel Capitan without any
ropes or safety gear the famed 3,000
foot rock wall is higher than the
tallest building in the world the Burj
Khalifa in Dubai his climb is the
subject of a new documentary called free
solo Honnold returned to the site of his
record-breaking triumph to write a note
to his teenage self about what lies
ahead right now you're an 18 year old
loner lost in the sea of uncaring faces
at UC Berkeley you'll spend most of your
freshman year not at class but at a
local boulder traversing the rock face
back and forth headphones in you prefer
to the climbing gym because you don't
have to talk to anyone
surprisingly this is the beginning of a
path you will leave school move into a
van and devote yourself to climbing your
lack of social skills will be one part
of why you take a free so line or
climbing without a rope but don't worry
you'll eventually find yourself right at
home in the climbing community
surrounded by close friends and lifelong
partners
you boys love the physical movement of
planning there's a certain joy in
swinging around propelling yourself
upward the fluidity of movement
whether it's climbing trees or buildings
as a kid
or climbing Half Dome and you somebody
national parks an adult you'll come to
appreciate the straining your arms and
the burning of your muscles you'll
experience this joy climbing throughout
your life no matter how many routes you
climb it will always be at the core of
your drive he scales walls higher than
the Empire State Building Alex Honnold
is a giant in the rock climbing
community no ropes no safety gear just
him in the rock the idea of free soloing
El Capitan the iconic 3,000 foot wall in
Yosemite or become an all-encompassing
dream for much of your climbing life for
the first five or six years you'll be
too afraid to try to afraid to even put
any effort toward a potential solo right
now you're afraid of so many things
strangers girls vegetables falling to
your death
that's fine
[Music]
fear is a perfectly natural part of life
you will always feel fear scary but over
time you will realize that the only way
to truly manage your fears is to broaden
your comfort zone it's a long slow
process that requires constantly pushing
yourself but eventually if we're pretty
darn good and you'll climb the big walls
just like this
you'll have near misses and frequently
think about death it'll change your
perspective little annoyances will melt
away there will always be people calling
you crazy or assuming that you have a
death wish that's fine
they don't see the amount of time and
effort that goes into preparation or
your drive to do something difficult
especially if it's never been done
before
[Music]
but you always find purpose in exploring
your own limits
don't let anyone else's opinion rein you
in
it doesn't matter what anyone else
thinks live your life in the way that
you find most fulfilling for many years
climbing will be the most important
thing in your life you will put climbing
before everything else but keep an open
mind eventually you will have a
wonderful girlfriend and a Charitable
Foundation
[Music]
in the end it all comes back to El
Capitan it will give your life direction
for almost a decade it will be your muse
the reason you get up early to train and
stay out for long days in the mountains
he achieved the holy grail of rock
climbing the day that you find me free
solo of half will be one of the most
satisfying of your life the first person
in history to solo climbed El Capitan
without ropes will also serve as an
important reminder that no summit is
more important than the long process of
getting
climbing is a lifelong journey use it to
learn and grow and Alex don't forget to
enjoy the view
[Music]
okay remember when he was here I know
listen over time you will realize the
only way to truly manage your fears is
to broaden your comfort zone it's a long
slow process that requires constantly
pushing yourself that's something all of
us can live by and yet I love how you
ranked fear of girls and vegetables
higher to do this the focus that it
takes obviously on the wall yeah but all
the prep that goes before it the daily
commitment to this that is what's
amazing and also the mental skill of
this I would like to know the camera
person shooting that going okay Alex we
can go on down amazing the New York
Times best-selling book note to self
inspiring words from inspiring people
features letters from our Emmy nominated
series it's published by Simon &
Schuster a division of CBS and is
available right now and you can hear
more of CBS this morning including
including extended interviews and
original content on our podcast that's
available on Apple's podcast app or
wherever you like to get your podcast